this is a production of Cornell
University
I want to show you a rare work at the
crossroads of criminal justice and
education these are two key
controversies in our society and their
intersection is not random we know that
people who end up caught in the criminal
justice system come from neighborhoods
with low quality schools amongst many
other things the experience of
incarceration tends to make tall
barriers to higher education even taller
meaning it's much less likely that
someone wind up in college if they end
up in prison first today I direct the
Cornell prison education program I have
something boastful to say here about our
program but i think it's not necessary
now that Don's giving that lovely
introduction the work i'll share with
you today is from the work i did before
cornell my project was an attempt to do
things in horticulture education that
were new new in prison in particular
possibly new an education that we've
known because of the oddness of the
environment of prison and the
constraints placed upon what is are now
the status quo things we expect from a
college classroom so what's new about it
is not so much the style of horticulture
education that i was getting at or
implementing or how it was sort of
somehow trying to do something
fundamentally different from campus what
is remarkable about the work is how far
i got in trying to make things the same
to how horticulture could be taught at a
good college campus I see I'm as I'm
looking out at you I see several folks
who participated in the Cornell prison
education program welcome actually could
we get a show of hands quick from who
you are so there's there's several
people here in this section over here
who've been involved in this and so they
will understand very well and and some
of them with no background in
horticulture the challenge of this talk
which is trying to both introduce things
about prison I presume for most folks in
here you've never been to a
high-security prison in America and at
the same time talk about the challenge
of doing education and at within that
the field of horticulture in particular
and what we try to do to have meaningful
labs and activities for students in
prison
so I was trying to demonstrate that it
was possible to do good education in
prison in the field of horticulture and
I hope to share some of that with you
today they're going to be three sections
to this talk maybe I tell me if I talk
too fast i've been told i can go rather
quickly but I've got a lot i'm trying to
do it i just laid out i'll try to
introduce quickly higher education in
prison itself and i'll give you a quick
five minutes on the cornell prison
education program then i'll talk a
little bit about the challenges facing
horticulture education and really still
education in per se but but specifically
horticulture and then i'll talk about
some of the things I did to respond to
the challenges so this five-minute
second is actually something I do on
campus to introduce the program when
we're recruiting faculty graduate
students and undergraduates who
participate in our program here a quick
introduction to why we would do college
in prison introducing the Cornell prison
education project itself and then the
broader context of correctional reform
and what we think the outcomes are when
we put post-secondary education in
prisons so education in prison is
nothing new this image on the left over
here is actually 100 years old Auburn
New York a prison we work in today
classroom adults learning grade school
level curriculum that's the reason we
call them correctional centers in
American societies there's this image of
rehabilitation in prisons the idea is
that you don't just put people in a cell
and abandon them for 10 years and expect
something dramatically different to
happen you rehabilitate them you offer
them program do you educate folks here's
an image from the 70s at when the Pell
grants were made available for the first
time you had financial aid in the United
States college programs entered into the
prisons and there was a era in which
college programs flourished in American
prisons speeding into the 80s and 90s
America was reeling from questions of
what to do about crime a lot of people
its many of us may be too young for this
but if you can remember the drumbeat of
politics back then was there's too much
crime this other politician hasn't been
harsh enough about crime this guy here
thinks people in prison should be taking
college classes I don't think so this
person here since you should only get
six months for this crime we're going to
give them 20 years
and you see over a couple of decades
this trend towards punitive pneus taking
away programs from people who've been
convicted of crimes specifically the
crime bill of 1994 made it illegal for
people in prison to receive Pell grants
overnight we end up with a lot of empty
classrooms where there used to be
college classes so the question then is
really what do we want to do when we
when there's harm in society when
someone's convicted of a crime we send
them away to a prison what do we what we
want to have happen with those
individuals currently these are the
status quo here we have a lot of
exercise yards you've probably seen
these images if you read the New York
Times just kind of a drumbeat right now
of we aren't doing a lot of productive
stuff in there we might even be making
folks more dangerous making license
plates actually happens it over in
prison that's a photo from there and
this is a site that I saw actually down
the hall from where my classroom was in
Illinois where a gym is turned into a
bunk bed unit because of the
overcrowding of prisons because people
don't to spend money on this but they
don't have another answer right now
currently than just more and more
incarceration do you end up with that so
it doesn't even taking away exercise so
okay so now we've got folks that are
literally just in a sort of refugee kind
of situation this is an image from a
Cornell classroom happening at Auburn
prison we've got a pair of graduate
students at the front here aidan Lear's
and dance Anakin the year before both of
them pulled down professorships aidan's
at suny oswego and then how did Grinnell
teaching a literature seminar these are
students many in the room will recognize
from this section over here having a
conversation about literature then these
classes count in our partnership with a
community college towards an associate
degree Bob in the room here in this
photo along with Ron Seaver as well as
the president and provost of cayuga
community college who work with Cornell
in order to make an associate's degree
accessible to these 15 men who graduated
on this particular day in 2012 and in
the middle we have a philanthropist key
theme of this work without financial aid
you basically have no tuition revenue
the folks that are in America's prisons
are of the lowest economic strata so
there's really no way to fund college in
prison let alone combat the political
that makes it so difficult to do this
without someone providing private
dollars and typically not the students
and here are the three persons that
Cornell operates in Auburn Correctional
Facility up in Auburn the medium
security prison-- down here in Moravia
very similar to the one I'll be
discussing the day in Illinois and a
maximum security prison in romulus
called Five Points correctional facility
very quick slide about outcomes this is
a an image of a couple of our former
students Sean who I presented at a
conference in nashville with last week
is now part time student at Columbia
John another one of our former students
is a carpenter in town and here is
actually participating in building
homeless shelters with an organization i
think in kamon county and some of our
undergraduates as they go out into the
world many of whom get involved in the
intersection between criminal justice
and the other fields they've studied in
wearing green chords and the graduation
ceremonies are undergrads wear green
cores to symbolize the the green prison
uniforms that our students on the inside
of the prison walls
they're good question done um there are
no prisons that have a mix of both
genders so so just to go back is it
there yeah these are all male prisons
and so yeah we could talk about that one
day so a lot of questions it raises for
folks Oh ah yes to Geneva the question
was those are a lot of women coming from
Cornell and to a prisoner the prison's
male and female are mixed and the answer
was no these are men's prisons and that
that I can kind of guess where that
conversation would go let's maybe wait
pull off on them
Willard okay so actually the woman on
the line here is sharing that right next
to Five Points correctional facility
right over here there's a drug treatment
and rehabilitation center which actually
is one of the main alternatives I kind
of count that as a non prison in a way
it's a it's a confinement facility but
it's intended to be a short stay and
release where you're being treated for
drug treatment and it is a
co-educational thank you okay I'm trying
to zoom ahead here so let's talk a
little bit about this product I hadn't
Illinois and the challenges faced by a
person who wants to just bring a solid
horticultural education into the place
folks who want to do something positive
with their lives have a chance to do
something better why am I going back to
the challenges after having just spoken
about the denial of financial aid and so
on because there are many other issues
both broad and specific to this
presentation which undergird the work
and present tremendous conflicts the
broader problem is that we have 2.3
million people in prison about 6.7
million people under correctional
supervision that's parole and over 70
million people currently alive with
criminal records as we think about these
the challenges to employing and
generating you know gainful positive
futures for our society out of that
negative resume that all those folks are
carrying with them that's what we're
trying to combat here as an institution
of higher learning we're in a position
to offer education right so that's what
is a university do in prison probably
educate but generally the population we
find in prison lacks access to good
education they haven't had a good
background they don't come from the best
high schools they aren't web designers
already they aren't coming with all the
skills that a lot of our students would
come from they come from communities
with inconsistent institutions
inconsistent mother tongue languages and
there's no ladder in front of them good
high school to a good two-year college
to a good four-year college and so
that's usually the path that we try to
construct on the inside in this case in
Illinois I was really trying to defy the
odds I might have to fly through some of
this but the main thing the folks have
been in prison before you might chime in
in the QA
to work within the system to change it
is tremendously difficult any campus
educator who doesn't know the
constructional environment what might be
surprised to learn that now generally
there's no one on one conversations
there's no internet there is no email
there are no office hours there will be
no phone calls or notes with your
students there's barely any library
resources of an academic type you can't
just name drop in your class because
your students can go to Wikipedia and
look up the name of that person that you
were referencing now common items are
considered potential weapons or
contraband including scissors large
paper clips DVDs chewing gum sugar
packets anything made of metal or glass
etc you can imagine now that why I'm
saying a majority of what I'm trying to
do is just do a normal education in
prison because what you see a lot of
times when you go into prison is these
kind of aberrations of reality why are
we doing it this way it's because these
rules have made it impossible to do it
in the regular way to put it in
perspective many of the things I
accomplish in the Illinois prison system
thus far have been impossible for us to
accomplish here in upstate New York with
the Cornell prison education program a
lot of that derives from the fact that
the program i did in Illinois I had made
this decision to try to work inside the
system i infiltrated the system as
opposed to Cornell's which is from
without so just to give you an image of
this teachers generally I presume in my
colleagues throughout the world don't
have the experience of calling a
watchtower on a walkie-talkie to tell
them that they're moving 11 inmates to a
garden with shovels I had a
walkie-talkie I had keys and I had to
secure every single tool when they
weren't in use on the other hand I was
the only person in the facility during
day shift with a PhD I attains the
Appalachian dock folks who knew me as
the one person around was highly
educated and trying to create an
intellectual culture there and I was
really trying to understand the
structural challenges that that were
surmountable to make it possible to have
a real rehabilitative educational
program there so those are the
challenges facing horticulture in prison
I will do them
quickly the anti rehabilitation culture
of the prison competition from other
units in the facility and then inmate
cynicism and so if you think about it
this is really the overall anti a
rehabilitation and the sort of inside of
the components of the prison and then
person by person challenges there's a
lot of challenges so after the denial of
Pell Grant so we might be feeling this
this week in our country a lot of ways a
change in policy or a change in
political era will come with a feeling
of mandate and so correctional staff are
in bold in the feel like it was all
right to oppose all forms of Corrections
in the 90s um not just formally because
there aren't Pell grants but also
informally to say dr. Owens is here I
don't see why he has to come in here I
don't see his name on the list I'm not
gonna let him in today and just and just
this kind of micro resistance to
education barriers were set up
everywhere we lost the keys to that
classroom we're not using it today this
type of thing and this persists to this
day there was rampant racist and sexist
statements in my experience of working
at this prison on a daily basis and this
is something I think even our folks at
work at from the program at Cornell
don't hear as much that the gender
binary of the systems really makes a
very very macho environment in these
places that's why i Don's question is
really right on what's what happens when
you send women and it really permeated
the day-to-day experience of the
facility I'm going to talk about the
this in a little bit more detail so I
actually kept the log of all the stuff
because I this was upsetting it was
traumatizing to me I was hearing my
students described in a way I didn't
like right and people opposing my
mission so this is my therapy I actually
would just say today someone called one
of my students a dog today someone
called one of my students a [ __ ] you
know these visas these kind of racially
loaded words and i worked with this
author james Lowen
who is at american university in DC he's
a historian he wrote this book called
son downtown's he would grow up in
Decatur Illinois I mean so he remembers
there were these towns called son
downtown's Ivan if you've heard about
them the quick thing is towns in the
early 20th century in Illinois would
have put signs on the border of the town
who say things like whites only within
city limits after dark or the more
common one and a slightly more vulgar
one if the Sun Goes Down and you your
ass is brow and you better get out of
town or a lot of times there's a dark
colored donkey you know just running and
I was the image and this was a way of
announcing that these towns didn't let
black people live there you could work
there but when the Sun went down you had
to be out of town so why are we bringing
this up I worked in a place where there
are a lot of sundown towns in the past
now there's prison towns let's look at
carterville real quicks is up from some
of my research this is actually a place
where I had to go for my training it was
a son downtown in the old days wore
black folks go if they could work in
Carterville in the old days but they
couldn't actually live there this little
town called cope up here this is all
documented in that book I just
referenced City Council statements real
estate records and so on and so when I
went to carterville for my training I
just check this out because I was
curious I'd already been working in the
department of corrections I was like
what's going on here and so I went to
cope i went to carterville and i went to
john logan College which is where
they're now it's now the training center
for Southern Illinois for the Department
of Corrections I don't think most people
would know the John Logan if you go back
in time was the guy basically made his
political career on what's called the
Negro exclusion eggs and quotes like
this language anymore but his career was
started in trying to exclude black folks
from Illinois has really Illinois Smoove
we remember it today is the land of
lincoln so I know this is my colleagues
in Illinois sayings it done before and
this is some of this stuff you know
people want to hear this today but this
is empirical this is this actually
occurred and i want to say specifically
here I went to cope because I was
driving from northern area here it's not
an all white sorry is not an all-black
settlement and carterville is not an all
white settlement today it really is not
the Sun downtown system so don't
misconstrue what I'm trying to say here
we no longer live in the system cope is
basically we call it like a trailer
settlement a lot of low income
my folks there when i went to john logan
College a lot of black folks were going
to college there so we're really not in
that system anymore but that was a
legacy where are we at today this is the
1952 map of where the Sun downtown's
were in southern Illinois and so cities
that are denoted by all caps and bold
where the known sundown towns of this
region you see I've got carterville on
the red block there that's the prison I
was working in and it extends up to
Northern Illinois a lot of people know
about Cicero and certain cities of her
famous for this up north today this is
where we have prisons in jails in
southern Illinois and so these are
basically prison towns jail domes and so
you know we could say to ourselves well
maybe we've just completely got rid of
racism in the sixties all went away
there's nothing of nothing correlating
between these two whatsoever it just
happens to be a comparable number about
50 to sundown towns in about 60 46 jail
towns this is the thing that really
drives the field in a lot of ways this
is a charter this will be hopefully out
in an article next year in american
studies of the incarceration rate in the
state of illinois and so you can see if
we're go back to 52 we've got around
8,000 people in jails and prisons in
illinois and about a sick and these pie
charts down here carry along they don't
always report demographic data for
various reasons in the correction system
but about sixty percent white back then
and about less than a quarter in 1999
the last time i had data and so this is
basically up to the time of the work I
was doing now the other thing I want to
point out here is the line the dashed
line is just counting facilities
according to this numeration here so the
best time in a certain sense to be in
prison in Illinois would have been here
because the number was the lowest about
6,000 people in jail you had 11
facilities that means people are the
most space the most the highest inmate
to staff ratio if they were involved in
programs and and then when you see them
starting to close prisons here while the
number keeps going up we're both 50,000
right now that's the overcrowding so
anti rehabilitation culture of the
prisoners very true this just made the
whole project all the more loaded
because not only are you trying to say
hey could you help this student get from
the housing unit over the classroom this
person's later whatever but you've got
this constant drumbeat of these folks
are really not worthy of things not
always in explicit racial terms but a
lot of times in terms of just because
they're considered criminals or inmates
they just don't deserve an education
that's just the mood of the police
alright competition from other prison
functions so here's how the prison works
this is an actual prison it's a google
map the orange house units X houses as
we call them had 400 people each of them
a once missing left wing it's solitary
confinement unit over there was cut off
that there's a school in gym that's
where my classroom was perimeter fence
keeps everyone in and then this extra
fence there blocks off the exercise yard
and in the purple room there you have
some folks making cardboard boxes in
prison uniforms every prison usually has
some industry where they try to produce
something about 20 inmates had access to
that out of about 1,600 1,600 inmates at
this facility ok but so here's the thing
the prison administration and security
personnel in general preferred to
limitanei moving all together unless it
was completely necessary so just to get
a student from the school building to
the garden which we'll talk about in a
second was a tremendous act of acting
asking for permission and you can this
is how they like it so here's an ex
house in Illinois the grass has been
pretty poorly treated they know no one's
moving there's no trees there's no
people this is just a completely
controlled environment you can see if if
people didn't want to send folks after
the exercise yard you could just say
exercise in here today so when I was in
this area I had to watch towers on the
other side of the garden and so there
was always this kind of constant
surveillance of things and so and you
can imagine then if you've got a party
that's in the watchtower it's kind of
looking to stop education they basically
had a kind of constant micro managerial
kind of thing they were doing of saying
I think I saw someone do something wrong
there uh so they can get on a
loudspeaker from a from a watchtower and
say inmate so-and-so come over here or
you need to go back to the classroom or
whatever
so this is these for the resistances
zooming in a little bit more you can see
here's the school's I'd have to walk out
here to do this and you can see there's
a greenhouse so this is actually I mean
the main thing years this should be an
environment of a huge opportunity that's
a 0.9 one acre garden space that's been
pre-established at the prison and a
greenhouse here's the thing there was
this grounds crew at the prison which
yeah I'm going to break the seal and say
the prison was corrupt and stool pigeons
got to be in the grounds crew and so the
grounds crew got the green house and the
garden before I established this sort of
funding apparatus by which we could have
a horticulture program and I had to work
really hard politically to get access to
this greenhouse for my students and I
could not get access to the greenhouse
so that was the place that basically a
collection of ten inmates on this
grounds crew which would do lawn mowing
including lawn mowing outside of the
fence driving tractors around raking
leaves to the extent that retrieves
getting ice off the sidewalks they could
hang out in a greenhouse in the cold
winter when all the housing units were
fairly cold and most people didn't have
any space because we're stuck in a small
cell they could be in a greenhouse
growing poinsettias for the
administrator's office and so they
didn't they never in the two and a half
years I was in this program let our
program use greenhouse this is really
problematic this is actually the only
photo I have of myself in the classroom
and so this is actually the classroom in
the school building you can see these
tall sort of warehouse like walls no
windows at me I'm in a green hoodie here
hit no idea camera person was coming um
you can see some of the students here
you can also see there's some folks on
computers back there and yeah so imagine
after the first frost when the garden is
effectively not useful any longer in
terms of doing new projects waterlogged
etc that you know the grounds cruel
control of the greenhouse is
particularly frustrating and
talk more about that so the inmate
cynicism about vocational you so finally
then you have this question of how do
you find good students in here I'm try
to do this quick this is actually the
only thing that the state of Illinois
does in terms of post-secondary
education opportunities when
universities and colleges don't have
proactive campaigns like Cornell's and
the University of Illinois program
that's where I came from so here's
Danville it's got three types of courses
that are offered automated technology
horticulture and career technology what
are those three things the automotive
quickly got automotive tech that was um
doing custom paint jobs on correctional
officers cars and trucks for free or for
the cost of the paint souping up their
engines I remember people detailing
carburetors and putting like insignias
and American flags on the different
parts of the cars and stuff and that was
that and then career tech was a six week
class and what you learned how to turn
on a computer and use Microsoft Word so
that's that's the status quo and to
which what you're about to see me trying
to do comes in a brief comment on jobs
everyone always wants to exclamation of
this it's just one paper of chart from
2012 study comfortable time in Indiana
right next door to where we were at in
terms of what kind of job outcomes in a
group of five thousand or more folks had
over five years sequence and these red
blob boxes are just trying to show any
overlap with in the way this paper
defined it the categories of
post-secondary education that are
offered in the prison it doesn't even
get into what are the cells just put
asterisks academic programs have a much
wider range of outcomes I was just
talking with Tommy ervell one of our
folks those in our program the one of
Columbia is now an uber driver another
who's now at Lehman College is a
registered nurse another who's going to
that school of business in baruch
college is a paralegal John's a
carpenter so carpentry so there are so
there's some overlap but our that's the
whole point of having a liberal arts
education is we think that
this liberal arts education will lead
you to a proper consideration of having
a examined life finally good time is a
hundred-year-old concept that going
really fast that's what I said I
wouldn't do check it out there's an old
idea in prison which is you got a bunch
of people there in prison they did
something bad they're gonna get released
one day a lot of them are gonna come
back to prison for doing another bad
thing what if you could take some of
them figure out some activity to give
them that would guarantee that when they
go out there productive and they become
taxpayers and they don't come back
that'd be really valuable to the state
right so you could take that activity
and actually credit them and give them
time off their sentence you could
incentivize them to become these good
people so that's called good time so a
hundred years on that has become the
most pinata concept it is so
bureaucratized and and barrier ridden
that it's almost impossible to implement
this in a good way if nothing else I'm
highlighting here that the very
definition of it in Illinois said that
people who had violent offenses sex
offenses or anything involving a weapon
so even if I go into a store and no one
gets hurt but I said I have a knife on
me you're never getting good time crazy
review I won't even explain this to you
but basically the time it takes to get a
few months off your sentence it starts
all the way in the courthouse before
you're in prison and extends all the way
to the day of your release and there's
six different layers of review you
basically would spend more time doing
the getting the good time than getting
off of your sentence by now here the
actual people that got good time from my
program at about 120 people over those
two years take classes with me 14
students were eligible at all everyone
who's eligible tries to do it and they
fill out contracts typically I've got
about three out of it if they were to
take all my courses so days are credited
towards release from prison and then the
rule in Illinois as you get half of that
number of days off of your sentence so
you can actually calculate out the
number of days or in this case I did it
by years of sentence reduction that my
course generated multiply that by the
cost per person in prison and there's a
cost savings to the state of about 35
a thousand dollars I just want to point
this out these ones with parentheses
these are folks that didn't get the
credit in the end their contract was
voided because again they did you know
inmate was out of place got written up
throughout their good time or whatever
had had a pen that was unauthorized
throughout the good time so there would
have been actually much more but in
eligibility and that that kind of
constant rule micromanagement
interviewed with this finally this is
the real point people then become hugely
cynical about this so some of these
these are my worst students because
these are the folks that were basically
like okay I'm stuck at Danville I've got
another three years in prison what do we
got here automotive tech I don't want to
go detail some officers car career-tech
well that's only six weeks so I'm only
getting like just turn on a computer and
get out of there only thing you can get
a couple weeks off your sentence anyway
there's this doc scott guy and he's like
making everyone got to a garden okay
I'll try that and they would be the
students that would be there saying if I
get out of my chair will I lose good
time if I get a c-minus can i still have
a good time if I don't come to class
tomorrow because I feel sick am I going
to get good time we credit the day for a
good time if I leave early today because
I have a virus and so that was just the
constant conversation and so this
actually is just another barrier so it's
just an example of a on the individual
level bear here to this stuff okay is
what we want to hear responses to the
challenges I need to underscore how rare
and unheard of this work is you will
hear me now reference a garden with
hundreds of species of plants a library
with thousands of titles on itself
computers in the classroom students
participating in the construction of
meaningful projects aimed at helping
their fellow men this is really against
the odds and the infighting environment
of prison and against considerable
resistance of course said there's not
many times i'll spare you
here's the three parts of this are two
parts of this sections can be quick so
we can have some QA this is
fundamentally everything this education
work is about is trying to respond to
this contentious environment and really
hopefully particularly this week
creating an environment where people can
really have a discussion with each other
and try to understand each other and try
to move forward into a fruitful future
together and then I'll talk a little bit
about some of the specific things that I
did there's a classroom my top guys in
2013 for the University of Illinois and
my other hat which is an educational
researcher and I just want to point out
like look at the mood in this room so
it's an all-male facility right these
guys are not in a mode of being
dangerous psychopathic leave any little
micro thing they do is going to be a
trouble these this is a community that
formed around our program you can see
part of the library here's the library's
spread over three rooms the way that we
did it we get to sit at seminar tables
we're reading research articles and I
know all these people this is the main
difference between folks that do this
work firsthand like some of the folks
here in the room and folks that talk
about this and write about it but have
never visited I know that Johnny page is
in governor State University today
Michael Braun guy from New Jersey like
me cavanon Elam is about to publish an
article in Harvard educational review
came out of some of this educational
work we did there the prison's trying to
block him from publishing it it's on a
really dangerous topic of how education
for prisoners could enhance democracy by
having people have informed voices so
Harvard likes it administration not so
much this guy's a person who's now a
teacher in a Catholic school and morelia
in Mexico he was deported even though he
was brought to us when he was one year
old sentence without evidence at the age
of 15 he did 15 years and the person
who's my age and has now been moving
living in Mexico where he'd never lived
before and and he's a Catholic school
teacher and is a wife of the friend of
mine she said working like college so
these are all people with names to me
they're all people that are actually
doing things that are good and that's
that's the thing to remember through all
this let's get into what i was doing
here this is actually i didn't know they
were going to take this photo either it
was the day of my job interview where
they said look we till it up the land
for you check this out and i talked to a
bunch of people who know nothing about
horticulture who hired me to do this all
right
and I provided the funding for myself so
you know back to the fundamental
challenge of having no tuition money now
we're looking at a USGS soil survey for
the site here's where the garden would
be the interesting thing here is that
you can toy folks to be familiar with it
so you're looking at a Caitlyn series
but the Midwest soils are typically mala
cells and alpha cells the garden was in
a particularly boggy area this is one of
the things that made this land not too
valuable to the Mennonites who are
actually who sold it to the state in the
early 80s and made it into a prison so
it turns out the garden is right in the
spot that made the site completely
invaluable as a place to do agriculture
I surrounded by corn and soybean fields
oh and also just no here's the Indiana
border so I was comparing to Indiana for
you basically and you're you're in a
Cell on that side of building here i'm
looking at indiana all rights get in
here so we made maps of this stuff this
is this is by itself a huge feet imagine
an environment in which a string that's
this long is considered contraband
because you could put it around
someone's it's never happened in this
prison but that's the type of thing they
say in the kind of constant looking for
criminality mindset that runs the place
so let alone a tape measure which is
metal which even worse so we actually
had to manufacture the tools to do this
and I would send supplement what we were
doing with satellite photos as you can
see to try to produce sufficient
drawings to show what we're trying to do
the red lines in this case are digging
little channels to drain the things so
they wouldn't allow us to install
culverts because you can hide weapons
and culverts so so we had to do this
type of thing you can see I'm just
trying to get the water to go in one
direction away from here and right away
tremendous food waste going on in prison
so the goal in New in Illinois is to
feed people on one dollar per day or
less the result is very low quality food
and the result is inmates going to the
cafeteria getting their food presented
to them eating the cookie and the rest
gets tossed so we very quickly got into
this composting work an image of what
we're trying to do the first year that
of course this is a final crown sighs we
didn't get any access to bring in full
size trees so we bought bare root
seedling trees and grafted trees in
order to start implementing this
it's just an image of what it looks like
the first year shouldn't be much
information here but you can see the
stakes are where we're putting the trees
and mulching it with grass clippings and
leaves and fresh compost we've made here
to be where we got by May so you can see
then a lot is is food so for another day
the whole thing of bringing nutritious
food into a place with the cafeteria
dynamics like I described is going to
have its own excitations and conflicts
latent into it now and we start getting
into this drought period this is
actually kind of devastating so there
was a drought right around a lockdown so
we couldn't go out there and water
plants they wouldn't let inmate movement
back to that and so this is where you
start getting triangulated by all these
constraints it must have rained one day
and someone took a photo it's the only
photo I have looking that way that ever
was taken so this is that building where
they make cardboard boxes the greenhouse
here and you can see we're starting to
put compost piles out here and when the
lockdown continued that you're in the
drought continued you can see the yellow
beds represent beds that basically
tanked when it got too dry the irony of
our waterlogged soil having been trained
properly we had to find some other
activities so I've worked at the
construction class when they wouldn't
let our students move they actually
produce proper compost bins and we get a
sort of rebounding of the garden when
they let us back out there and September
then it's a frost so again now you got
to imagine I've got a good six months or
more you know usda zone 5 so by seven
months in which it's not reasonable to
think that you're going to have much
productivity if you plant plants so what
do we do we start dividing up the garden
beds and offering the men opportunities
to kind of compete with each other to do
better designs for the different
sections of the garden we had
competitions for the spaces that were
common weird things like this showed up
on the computer this was made with ms
paint i think and cut and paste i
actually don't know how mr. Stilson did
this this won the competition not
because it's reasonable because this
looks like water to me and i don't know
what that would do for the flower and
crab apple or whatever that is i think
i'm not even sure what species he
thought we were gonna plant here and
when this is pretty two-dimensional but
um the idea was we want a picnic table a
table and to try putting some elevation
to one of the trees so that because
people like sitting on these little
Stoops
and that then made it into the design
right so we actually you know started
kind of doing this type of thing we
ended up with river birch as the species
we were trying for there and you can
kind of see as we're going along hear
that a lot was developing in 2013 I
should say for another day there was a
whole project of Illinois at sporting me
across the state to implement our
composting system i'm not i'm going to
tell you about that but the composting
thing was huge because of the tens of
thousands of dollars of waste expenses
that the facility incurred and this
being a way to process things back into
the site we started using the
construction classroom which is
abandoned to produce cement papers by
hand and to teach the dynamics of
construction and portland cement and
angry and all that stuff and get these
things out here so you could walk
through the Prairie you can see this was
supposed to be getting designed as a
Japanese garden we had a lot of ideas
and cornell university offered me a job
so that's where we stopped i want to say
i needed to get out of there just you've
heard me i'm coming i'm giving you
actually a fairly sanitized version of
this this was grading psychological work
for me i was working every weekend i was
constantly bringing in books pdfs trying
to get clearance through a bunch of
people that didn't want me to do this so
i don't recommend anyone do this I mean
I was trying to I was doing the Superman
thing the sort of martyred teacher
trying to make it possible to do this
thing in the impossible environment and
when I left a lot of my students had
also done this educational academic work
with me and they said what are you going
to say when you leave here I said I'm
gonna say this is my time in the
trenches I tried to get into the system
and make a change and we're still hated
here there's still a bunch of messes
with what this is there's lockdowns and
for nothing if we uh here's a satellite
image they mowed it after i left i'm
told so this is supposedly September of
2013 you can still see some shadows
which suggests that maybe some some
shrubs there have survived but you can
see the paper stones you can see the
curly river and I could say a few things
about the other stuff we did and then
you can
ask me more about this so other
responses to some of these challenges
I've laid out to you there's this
greenhouse simulation type of thing I
did with grow lights we tried to make
labs work very challenging design
competitions practice exams and student
produce field guides you've maybe seen
one of these things I generally don't
love these things I mean makes a lot of
sense to do without the lights but if
you've got nothing but vertical space
this is how you do it and this is in an
all cement room and I got two of these
things on that state budget based on the
fact that i used the logic of good time
i got the state to give me an
appropriation to buy two of these things
and give every 12 trays of plants they
could mess around with in the winter and
i would engage the students in the real
study of biodiversity so we had a
student from cameroon we studied the
plant the flora and fauna cameroon we
started growing baobab trees from seed
and these trays and declared that there
would be a bell bad bonsai garden anyway
we also got say cold frames that was
another things we put cold frames there
and also in other places in the garden
that we've walked by as a way to try to
get movement and try to get truly
normalize it at the facility I don't
know why I'm showing this one I'm
showing this one because you see these
things on people's desks those so you're
not out of glass but there were peanut
butter jars that people would buy in the
commissary I mean the guys would scrub
them clean and not really allowed but
somehow they ended up in the classroom
and what I'm doing there is people
should be familiar with it's the soil
shake test it's an old trick to
introduce people to sew a particle size
you know shake up a sample in some water
and it's sediments out and you know you
can use this oil triangle and give some
approximation of what type of so you've
got so this is the type of thing I would
have to do is like figure out what could
happen through this and what could
happen through that I'm just giving
examples from the soil class because
that's happened to be one that I had at
hand we actually did soil pits dug them
and check out shovels and checked out
the different stratification of soil
layers I would take peds of the soil
home photographic because there's no
cell phones in prison there's no cameras
available take it home photograph it and
add it into the worksheet so people
could see what we're getting at and so
all these other things you might be
surprised to hear you can have a piece
of string you can have a piece of metal
but
what it looks like to get a bunch of
inmates to dig a 60-inch soil pit right
next to the fence of a prison inside of
two watch towers with a hose sitting
around that you could throw over the
fence I mean that business with this you
get an image of kind of my world just
trying to explain that to a bunch of
correctional officers folks that we're
using the Excel things started to offer
to make crossword puzzles every again
we're in soil here but this would be an
entire week production they trade it off
and do a kind of blind review of each
other like okay we got this thing and it
was actually I'm widget eyes Dwinell
things so that when you type in wrong
letters it would give you the sense that
you got them wrong and there's some kind
of winning up the whole thing field guys
this was another thing that the skin
keeping the students occupied in
thoughtful activity all day we that we
allow the students to produce this field
guide thing in them in PowerPoint
getting towards the end I know we're
getting late um there's one birch tree
in the entire place we show so I bring
in images of a show it was actually
there there were this was a section
header so is this is no frills
PowerPoint feel good but this is a plane
you saw all the time you were always
kind of amazed we haven't even touched
on the fact that most of these guys are
coming from urban areas where there's
not a lot of plants and I would say the
name of the plants in the sidewalk and
it was always like doc knows like way
too many plants and so this is a way to
kind of say bring in a picture that give
us the name we're going to compete with
you arrive and we're going to note these
planes too so the weed section you'd see
personally and people particularly loved
it there this was like semi edible plan
or whatever but it's also ubiquitous in
Chicago the animal one is actually
really interesting because a lot of this
animal diversity only showed up because
of the plant diversity that we had with
the perennials and the drainage regime
and doing different things to make
habitat not intentionally for the
animals but as a side effect so this is
just a short list from an early version
of this this is an animal those
ubiquitous in Chicago and some people
don't even know it's also in the prison
you can hear it so this is even to have
this in a prison environment where you
could hear
look at and learn the name of and the
habitat of animals that you're seeing in
great flocks I mean I'm talking about
you got dumpsters of wasted soy food for
inmates covered with crows every morning
and people don't know if it's a crow or
a grackle or a starling or whatever this
was a real moment this was probably most
interesting over the years when we have
that drainage change we got there late
goin crawfish returned to the garden
probably from there from hundreds of
years ago right there somehow they were
hanging out in the drainage ditches I
suppose around the prison and there and
someone who's staying in the garden you
hear this holler go up there's a lobster
in my garden and of course the
watchtowers are like everyone hold still
and it really like what's going on but
so obviously this is a way to side of
codify and make it into a learning
moment when these things would come
around finding these things in your
guard but is that a good thing do I want
this bug in here is this a bad thing
what it what our worm castings are all
over my garden bed we put a lot of
compost in there and this is the final
thing I'm going to say about this and
I'll just do a wrapping statement we
basically had you can't see the cursor
here but we made these it's a hypertext
so you know again absence of computer
literacy a real liberal education you
don't need to just give a career tech
class you can teach writing you can
teach genetics and through that
introduced to people to reading pdfs
could be email other things in this case
hypertech so you could click on the the
word crawfish and you'll go to it you
could click on the word earthworm and
it'll go to that slide so so folks we're
actually getting a very elementary
introduction to how the internet works
have you been in prison since the 90s
you've never lived in a society that has
cell phones just think about that for a
second how are you how do you get a
housing today computer you get a job
computer just imagine what folks are
facing when they come in
closing comment these were attempts to
bring horticultural education into
prison as I said at the beginning the
point near was not that I was trying to
develop a special prison education that
is totally different but rather than
education that would be to the greatest
extent possible the same as a good order
culture education would be at a decent
quality college campus I really only
know of one other program that got as
far as the Danville project in terms of
including a pedagogy of sustainability
it's called the sustainable prisons
program it's I got to visit it when i
was at UM never ever been state college
in washington but none of the other
projects i've seen have been as hands-on
in the practice of food production while
simultaneously introducing an academic
body of scholarly research and building
ladders of opportunity that lead up to a
university education and so on the
limits to what was possible here were
largely the consequences of my decision
to work inside the prison and for
various reasons while there are
different limits I'm inclined to say the
better point of leverage is to work from
without the prison system i really do
think that is the proper place for
universities to work and that's where we
find the work of the cornell prison
education program and that's it i thank
you for your time i welcome your
questions and you're welcome to contact
we're supposed to many unfamiliar to you
can describe how the university without
an agenda what is that
well the main thing is frankly the the
psychological turmoil is much lower for
someone that at least him come back to
campus at all times and can have a
community it really that's what the
corners of education program is provided
it is a sense that we were not to prison
since there's a reason we're not
fundamentally we're trying to create a
culture of learning provide
opportunities to people who are willing
to work to apply to our school to gain a
positive credential that will deal with
them for the rest of life in prisons are
about these people have been caught
doing something wrong we're going to
detain them and constrain what
opportunities they have and give them a
permanently negative record for the rest
of area so we have to be different from
it we can't just know this kind of
dialectic you can try to have a spot
where there's a collaboration but
working there I felt myself becoming I
can't really don't know how to put this
and that's what happened to those other
teachers that are described I haven't
even talked about the GED teachers I
mean you've got classroom that if gonna
turn into a piece of the prison garage
because of the bad power day and I don't
want to run a program like that I don't
think that's the place the university's
ultimately find yourself the best
position to do real research on what
else bonita we fundamentally sign you
off if you're never going to be able to
publish anything ever going to talk
about anything to get there and I
mentioned it down when I started is one
of the reasons they really put the
fright into you of police power and so
yeah a very hesitant and skittish to say
anything the repercussions would have
gone to my students who I want to see
turning into those jerk
other question yeah so in the court of
garden based learning we work with folks
statewide and the number of settings and
we have for many years and our our
guidance to folks whenever we begin
working with
starts to do a really stellar job with
something really small working with
everybody across all the layers of
administration and to do a beautiful job
you can always grow and you know just
watching this I'm both like wow and
tired out from the presentation if you
were to do it again and looking back on
what I mean you called yourself you know
the Superman approach what would you do
initially and do just an absolutely
stellar thorough thoughtful amazing job
knowing you know all the rest can follow
if you have a successful experience how
would you begin again can you briefly
yes so this question is given the hell
expensive and Superman light that I was
attempting to be here and that I've
heard that definitely let's get out of
this what would you say to someone else
who's coming into this what would you do
different
and would it be worth it to consider us
a small good success instead of a big
for now yeah I think that you've barely
got some some insights there and as
candidly I was really trying to provoke
the edge between the very tight
environment and you know the liberal
education interested in seeing being a
contributor to come just a few things I
would refuse to take this job if they
didn't give a winter break a spring
break a summer break and some off time
for the students particularly in the
winter I'd be fine to be that intensive
for nine months and had to be a
nine-month of what they wanted it to be
12 months I mean I work today and after
before and after Thanksgiving it worked
December 24th January first and these
guys were abandoned by to put everything
else so a lot of us here notice who were
from the prison program when you leave
those students in the prison it can be
emotionally hard to do this and so it
became a way that I dealt with it was to
just dive in the better thing would have
been to say was have a period of rest if
folks at voc and let they'll get over so
the teacher can put her I would also
start off with a kurta I basically
developed this curriculum no know how
much it is just to develop a syllabus I
at least be developed nine courses on
those for six months that I've been cut
quite the teaching load was absolutely
unsustainable and community colleges are
often guilty of this as a las through
their budget but I handed this off to
another person who took this on it and I
gave every single powerpoint
presentation I had actually begun to the
fluoride set up a situation like this
you could do over their projections the
library was in fact the cold Frank were
there walks in security tool room the
grow lights the tools to inmates that
were assigned to be assistance to the
program in that person learn after
teacher so but at least if I started
there I think would have been
interesting to see if I can 85 years two
minutes instead of two and then we have
um Cornell program is there's a kind of
dynamic carriages there's a lot of time
I found in group that really extends
them so far but then is also very
exposed because the facilities the
correctional folks see those like
individuals as having pushed it too far
and so you see the initial group kind of
pulled back a little bit in another
group I don't make something sustainable
this program still exists I don't know
the current teacher so it was hard but I
know they've got those computers there
and they've got these or some version of
what we started
thank you for doing this really I'm
really moved by your work there but I'm
wondering if you have any hope for shows
like orange is the new black what do you
think that could kind of galvanize
people towards prison reform efforts
just by bringing it to more to the
mainstream media and letting people see
the micro aggression with some things
that you're talking about that's
actually a very good question you know i
think that the media has played a big
role in the past years of wanting
portrayal of carceral spaces and that'd
be an example of it because pluses and
minuses to that show when you're really
in these places you and a lot of people
think that one prison they've seen is
representative of the whole system and
so any writer or any person like me can
fall into that fallacy but i think that
there's a lot better in just because i
know i haven't seen the series full but
i know there's a habit of going back and
showing where these stories started and
you heard almost everyone that I've got
a story about it's like starting at the
age of 12 certainly be 15 from the first
incarceration of hers and so it's hard
for us to blame our own built-in 15 year
olds for everything they can do because
they're obviously making bad choices and
so similarly there I think some of that
work is actually really good in building
some semblance of empathy between groups
the probably don't meet each other even
better I think its programs like
Cornell's programs which this semester
sending over a hundred people into three
correctional facilities to actually do
that ectly know these folks to actually
know what's going on when math phobia
kicks in and you realize i'm actually go
to college and I just had a real
psychological barrier around algebra and
I can get a college degree unless I get
past this but here's some folks from
Cornell a totally different community
than me totally different level of
access to the resources coming in anyway
and saying we're going to send you a
tutorial we're going to
fizik and help you with this we're going
to let you do it a second time review
this past failures and making it
possible and giving folks a chance to
decide whether they want to do it or not
only you learn the personality the life
stories opposed to do all this we're not
there is personal counseling but I do
you think that that actually there's a
movement for college in prison that's
the reason the White House was
interested in this work when begs the
way to us this Wednesday the one of our
former students to talk to the secretary
of education about the future through
school and it's because we need to bring
people together and I think that shows
can try to do that but there's also
definitely not sometimes they laugh at
that [ __ ] I mean sorry sometimes I can
tell like before laughing ready is it
because that character is tragically sad
and this is a quirky way presenting is
arif laughing at them because they're
being humiliated and we kind of enjoy
seeing people impossible situation and
all kind of contortions to survival
present building I think we're out of
time but i want to thank wrong for a
fascinating presentation so much this
has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell edu